ich habe heute ein thema mitgebracht was
mich in den morgenstunden sehr verärgert
hat und zwar ist mir aufgefallen dass in
thüringen in einer gießerei die auch die
thüringer allgemeine als erstes
berichtet hat dieses schild aus in einer
firma vor dem 1000 1000 raum und zwar
bisher kein vollständiger impfschutz
dort waren die leute abgebildet die noch
keinen impfschutz haben mit ihrem namen
also die mitarbeiter ich habe dann zum
telefon gegriffen und den chef der firma
angerufen ich habe jemanden an der
leitung gab der sehr beschämt war und
auch traurig darüber war nicht weil
jetzt darüber geschrieben wird oder
darüber berichtet wird natürlich mit
einem riesigen echo sondern weil er für
seine mitarbeiter eigentlich etwas gutes
tun wollte denn 80 prozent seiner
mitarbeiter seien geimpft und er hat
sich eine lösung überlegt wie wieder
mehr als einer zusammen im pausenraum
sitzen kann in seinen worten klang das
so wir haben ihn aus seinem unternehmen
auch selbst kritisch gesehen auch ich
fühle mich mit dem aushang nicht wohl
aber ich fühle mich auch nicht wohl die
masse meiner leute mit hygiene
schutzmaßnahmen zu drangsalieren die
nicht nötig sind wir haben aktuell eine
gemengelage die ganz schlecht ist als
unternehmer ist man aktuell ein
prügelknabe mainzer menschen schützen
aber darf nicht umsetzen wie soll ich
denn mitarbeiter schützen wenn ich nicht
weiß wen ich schützen soll er hat mir
ganz klar im gespräch gesagt dass er gar
nichts gegen die mitarbeiter hat die
nichts die nicht geimpft sind man kennt
mich ja die nach zuschauer als jemand
der sich über sowas extrem echauffieren
würde aber als ich ein unternehmer am
telefon erlebt habe der so der so ahnung
es ist ja so darüber nachgedacht hat was
jetzt also was daran falsch weil er
wusste es natürlich aber das möchte ich
mit der gruppe gerne debattieren auch
nicht endlich die regierung einfach
aufheben muss ticona maßnahmen den
freedom day einläuten muss damit sowas
einfach nicht mehr passiert bei der
unternehmer hat mir glaubhaft versichert
dass er niemandem seinem unternehmen
schaden wollte ja so lieben das sind
nicht nur die schnellsten 50 oder 55
minuten des tages für die zuschauer oder
sie wirklich schnellsten 55 minuten es
sind auch die differenzierten 55 minuten
hat eine brilliante zusammenfassung im
spannungsfeld des unternehmers der sich
da in diesem labyrinth der korona
maßnahmen zurechtfinden muss dass das
stimmt ich meine meine sympathie geht
auch zu den unternehmen die das ausbaden
müssen wir haben einen unternehmen wir
hier heute ich bin auch ein wir stehen
da zum teil im schwitzkasten da diese
etwas bis extrem willkürlichen maßnahmen
trotzdem ist und ich meine jede firma
darf das selber so regel innerhalb der
gesetze und ich meine wie man das macht
ist im grunde seine sache jetzt ich
persönlich finde so zusagt deutschland
vor allem für die ungeimpften das finde
ich eine ziemlich heftige maßnahme ob
das schöne an der privatwirtschaft ist
ja es gibt auch andere firmen und es
gibt eine auswahl und da kann man ja
wenn man sich daran stört und aus
mitarbeiter kann man ja zum beispiel das
wechseln aber was über das große problem
ist wenn der staat solche dinge an es
gibt nur einen start und dann kannst du
nicht entfliehen und darum bei aller
sympathie für den unternehmer wird
jedoch selbstkritisch ist ich finde ist
den rückweg das mittelalter nicht so
optimal mit dem staat und der
anprangerung aber ich sehe dass auch
meine
meinung dazu ich meine ja sogar zweig
restaurants wer ist so furchtbar für
eine arbeit der unternehmer hatte mir
auch berichtet dass alle mitarbeiter
waren damit der chor also er hat sie
gefragt und dann haben sie
unterschrieben dass es in ordnung ist
wenn ihr name und ihr bild da ist ich
finde diese maßnahme auch völlig absurd
ich hatte die augen geschlossen worden
die optimisten die abgebildeten waren
dafür ich denke aber dass auch der druck
ist natürlich da wenn der chef fragt ist
in ordnung aber das muss man auch noch
erwähnen die waren wohl dafür dass sie
dort abgewählt werden aber meine frage
war dann es können ja nicht alle dafür
gewesen sein weil war mich wohler angela
im netz genau die frage ist am ende auch
wenn das so anfängt wie geht es weiter
wenn er das ganze auf fangen wir jetzt
an auch dann in einer firma zu trennen
grippe geimpft nicht grippe geimpft
hätte ein arbeitgeber großes interesse
daran im zweifel denn die grippe
ausfälle möglicherweise auch gerade
dieses jahr die sind ganz schön heftig
gehen ganz schön ins geld eines
arbeitgebers also sehen wir dass bei
sieben vielleicht auch bald die gegen
röteln kämpften und die ging nicht
rütteln kämpften dass die sich dann
möglicherweise gegenüber stehen also bei
allem guten willen und ich würde dem
arbeitgeber jetzt auch gar nichts
schlechtes unterstellen dem firmenchef
aber glaube ich schon dass er ein
massiver spalter ist nämlich ein spalter
seiner belegschaft selbst wenn die das
sogar gut findet aber erteilt in
schlecht und in gut und das ist kein
gutes signal die gesellschaft spaltet
jetzt auch er bekommt nämlich
morddrohungen er und ganz furchtbare
anrufe irgendwie dass man ihm wünscht
dass er gegen den baum fährt und dass er
sich schämen sondern weiter als auch da
sieht man wie das hitze potenzial ich
greife das auch an aber das ausmaß dass
er heute beschrieben hat fand ich dann
auch schon wieder heftig muss ich doch
leicht widersprechen weil ich meine im
grunde hat der staat das vorgespult der
staat diskriminiert die ungeimpften der
staub macht die zweiklassengesellschaft
und dass da leute im unternehmen im
privaten sektor sich vielleicht auch
etwas unter diesem druck dann
entsprechend verhalten ich kriege sie
müssen kein widerspruch seien ursachen
vorher nicht wieder richtig wäre ein
traum für mich hier in sachen der
vorschau an den pranger hatte mich der
stabs der diese maßnahme machen aber
wenn ich das vielleicht noch hinzufügen
das hat man ja im fall des
fußballspielers gesehen kenne ich nicht
er hat sich auch nicht impfen lassen und
wird dann vom regierungssprecher
aufgefordert sich impfen zu lassen ihm
wird sozusagen eine vorbildfunktion wir
im fußball und im sport sicherlich hat
die impfbereitschaft angeht dann
vielleicht doch weniger und dem wird
auch
in gewisser weise an den pranger
gestellt indem man ihm sagt ja aber
selber muss sich jetzt impfen lassen und
wenn er das nicht gut an ist ein
schlechtes vorbild für das ganze land
das sagen und moralischer druck der da
ausgeübt also mit jeder müssen ja per se
vorbilder sein oder ja ja ja
eigentlich das stimmt wir sollten nichts
falsch machen also ich bin genesen und
geimpft auch mit überzeugung gekämpft
weil es gehabt habe und dass nicht mehr
mehr haben will aber ich denke auch es
geht so weit dass waskönig anbelangt
auch ein fußballspieler wenn er auch
vorbild ist wer als schön wenn er weder
geimpft werden natürlich
sollte und darf auch noch daher seines
eigenen körpers ein und so sehe es auch
es geht mir geht der chef zu weit das
dorf machen und die belegschaft wusste
wer geimpft ist und wer nicht geimpft
ist wenn wir es nicht sagen will dass
auch zeit nicht
aber aber so den den freedom day und so
das geht mir stück weit zu weit also der
der ausdruck friede und ergibt so weit
wobei ich mittlerweile der festen
überzeugung bin wir können den menschen
wieder allen die komplette freiheit
zurückgeben und auch die verantwortung
für die eigene gesundheit müssen wir
ihnen eigentlich zurückgeben es gibt
impfstoff wir wissen zum großen teil wie
man mit dem virus umgehen kann alles ist
noch nicht erforscht es gibt die
krankenhaus ampel also ich denke es ist
jetzt an der zeit dass man das ganze auf
maske weg und ich bin aber der
überzeugung dass manche noch die maske
tragen werden aus vorsicht das ist auch
okay freie entscheidung das freie
entscheidung wenn sie irgendwo sind bei
ihm sogar zum öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und die u bahn s bahn
bus ist proppevoll und ich will das so
dann soll das heute zu machen und ich
denke das werden auch einige tun aber
ansonsten haben wir jetzt eineinhalb
jahre es ist gut wir müssen auch lernen
und leben mit diesem virus umzugehen das
heißt das was ihr ministerpräsident
beispielsweise in bayern möchte nämlich
eine verlängerung auch der epidemischen
lage da würden sie das ganz klar
ablehnen und sagen nein das dass das
können wir nicht mehr machen die
epidemische lager muss auflaufen
auslaufen muss beendet werden und dann
ist sozusagen diese pandemie auch damals
ad acta gelegt
das sind jetzt zwei dinge also dass die
epidemische lage auslaufen soll da bin
ich dafür im august schon sehr kritisch
bei der verlängerung deshalb ist aber
die pandemie noch nicht vorbei und wenn
wir das gibt es auch noch man muss den
menschen schon noch sagen leute das ist
nicht vorbei und die krankheit wenn dich
erwischt das ist in vielen fällen auch
nicht einfach also die vorsicht schon
auch darauf hinzuweisen aber die ganzen
einschränkungen sie sollten jetzt den in
die hand der punkt ist ja auch der ich
freue mich die ganze zeit für wen stellt
eigentlich eine ungeimpfte eine
bedrohung dar wenn ich gehen ich bin
auch geimpft es hat einfach keinen habe
ich da keine psycho stress wenn jetzt
einer von habe ich nicht geimpft ist und
wenn wir wenigstens sitzen wir weit weg
wenn ich aufgrund meiner gesundheit ich
ein vor krankheit und da etwas zur
risikogruppe gehört kann ich mich
schützen also ich kann ja auch aus
gamestar einem ausgetragen man sagt mir
die maske nützen etwas also ich teile
ihre auffassung der stadt geht viel zu
weit reist eigentlich die verantwortung
für die gesundheit von den menschen an
sich es auch wir wissen besser rasiert
und ich machen müssen und deshalb sich
wieder aussteigen jetzt das geld nicht
die leute können doch selber ihre
gesundheit schützen man muss nicht
meinen die sind zu dumm dass wir das so
besser können für die es um ja auch eine
risikoabwägung das muss man auch sagen
es gibt ja im friesischen unbestrittener
weise gibt es im free sicken und
natürlich ist es eine individuelle
entscheidung diese risiken gegeneinander
abzuwägen ich glaube schon auch dass
eine impfung grundsätzlich etwas gutes
ist auch gerade im fall von corona aber
dass es leute gibt die die
risikoabwägung anders treffen als andere
leute das soll doch mal vielleicht
akzeptieren zumal es bei der impfung
selbstschutz geht und nicht um den
schutz um den schutz der der
gemeinschaft